OK, guys the -- we're almost
ready to make this lecture
immortal.
OK.
Are we on?
All right.
This is an important lecture.
It's about projections.
Let me start by just projecting
a vector b down on a vector a.
So just to so you see what the
geometry looks like in when
I'm in -- in just
two dimensions,
I'd like to find the point along
this line so that line through
a is a one-dimensional subspace,
so I'm starting with one
dimension.
I'd like to find the point
on that line closest to a.
Can I just take that
problem first and then I'll
explain why I want to
do it and why I want
to project on other subspaces.
So where's the point closest
to b that's on that line?
It's somewhere there.
And let me connect that and
-- and what's the whole point
of my picture now?
What's the -- where does
orthogonality come into this
picture?
The whole point is that
this best point, that's
the projection, P, of b onto
the line, where's orthogonality?
It's the fact that
that's a right angle.
That this -- the error -- this
is like how much I'm wrong
by --
this is the difference between
b and P, the whole point is --
that's perpendicular to a.
That's got to give
us the equation.
That's got to tell us --
that's the one fact we know,
that's got to tell us
where that projection is.
Let me also say, look --
I've drawn a triangle there.
So if we were doing
trigonometry we
would do like we would have
angles theta and distances that
would involve sine
theta and cos theta that
leads to lousy formulas
compared to linear algebra.
The formula that we want comes
out nicely and what's the --
what do we know?
We know that P, this projection,
is some multiple of a, right?
It's on that line.
So we know it's in that
one-dimensional subspace, it's
some multiple, let me
call that multiple x,
of a.
So really it's that
number x I'd like to find.
So this is going to
be simple in 1-D,
so let's just carry it
through, and then see
how it goes in high dimensions.
OK.
The key fact is --
the key to everything
is that perpendicular.
The fact that a is perpendicular
to a is perpendicular to e.
Which is (b-ax), xa.
I don't care what --
xa.
That that equals zero.
Do you see that as
the central equation,
that's saying that this a
is perpendicular to this --
correction, that's going
to tell us what x is.
Let me just raise the board
and simplify that and out will
come x.
OK.
So if I simplify that, let's
see, I'll move one to --
one term to one side, the other
term will be on the other side,
it looks to me like
x times a transpose a
is equal to a transpose b.
Right?
I have a transpose b
as one f- one term,
a transpose a as
the other, so right
away here's my a transpose a.
But it's just a number now.
And I divide by it.
And I get the answer. x is a
transpose b over a transpose a.
And P, the projection
I wanted, is --
that's the right multiple.
That's got a cosine
theta built in.
But we don't need
to look at angles.
It's -- we've just
got vectors here.
And the projection is
P is a times that x.
Or x times that a.
But I'm really going to --
eventually I'm going to want
that x coming on
the right-hand side.
So do you see that I've got two
of the three formulas already,
right here, I've got the --
that's the equation -- that
leads me to the answer,
here's the answer for x,
and here's the projection.
OK.
can I do add just
one more thing to
this one-dimensional problem?
One more like lift it up into
linear algebra, into matrices.
Here's the last
thing I want to do --
but don't forget those formulas.
a transpose b over a transpose
a.
Actually let's look at
that for a moment first.
Suppose -- Let me
take this next step.
So P is a times x.
So can I write that then?
P is a times this neat number, a
transpose b over a transpose a.
That's our projection.
Can I ask a couple of questions
about it, just while we look,
get that digest that formula.
Suppose b is doubled.
Suppose I change b to two b.
What happens to the projection?
So suppose I instead of
that vector b that I drew
on the board make it
two b, twice as long --
what's the projection now?
It's doubled too, right?
It's going to be twice as
far, if b goes twice as far,
the projection will
go twice as far.
And you see it there.
If I put in an extra factor
two, then P's got that factor
too.
Now what about if I double a?
What if I double the vector
a that I'm projecting onto?
What changes?
The projection
doesn't change at all.
Right?
Because I'm just --
the line didn't change.
If I double a or I take minus a.
It's still that same line.
The projection's still
in the same place.
And of course if I double
a I get a four up above,
and I get a four -- an extra
four below, they cancel out,
and the projection is the same.
OK.
So really, this --
I want to look at this
as the projection --
there's a matrix here.
The projection is carried
out by some matrix
that I'm going to call
the projection matrix.
And in other words
the projection
is some matrix that
acts on this guy b
and produces the projection.
The projection P is the
projection matrix acting
on whatever the input is.
The input is b, the
projection matrix is P. OK.
Actually you can tell
me right away what
this projection matrix
is.
So this is a pretty
interesting matrix.
What matrix is multiplying b?
I'm just -- just
from my formula --
I see what P is.
P, this projection matrix, is --
what is it?
I see a a transpose above,
and I see a transpose a below.
And those don't cancel.
That's not one.
Right?
That's a matrix.
Because down here,
the a transpose a,
that's just a number,
a transpose a, that's
the length of a squared, and
up above is a column times
a row.
Column times a row is a matrix.
So this is a full-scale
n by n matrix, if I --
if I'm in n dimensions.
And it's kind of
an interesting one.
And it's the one which if I
multiply by b then I get this,
you see once again I'm
putting parentheses
in different places.
I'm putting the
parentheses right there.
I'm saying OK, that's
really the matrix
that produces this projection.
OK.
Now, tell me --
all right, what are the
properties of that matrix?
I'm just using letters here, a
and b, I could put in numbers,
but I think it's -- for once,
it's clearer with letters,
because all formulas are simple,
a transpose b over a transpose
a -- that's the number that
multiplies the a, and then I
see wait a minute, there's a
matrix here and what's the rank
of that matrix, by the way?
What's the rank of
that matrix, yeah --
let me just ask you
about that matrix.
Which looks a little strange,
a a transpose over this number.
But well, I could ask
you its column space.
Yeah, let me ask you
its column space.
So what's the column
space of a matrix?
If you multiply that
matrix by anything
you always get in the
column space, right?
The column space of a matrix
is when you multiply any vector
by that matrix -- any
vector b, by the matrix,
you always land in
the column space.
That's what column spaces work.
Now what space do
we always land in?
What's the column space of --
what's the result when I
multiply this any vector
b by my matrix?
So I have P times b, where I?
I'm on that line, right?
The column space, so here
are facts about this matrix.
The column space of P, of
this projection matrix,
is the line through a.
And the rank of this matrix is
you can all say it at once one.
Right.
The rank is one.
This is a rank one matrix.
Actually it's exactly
the form that we're
familiar with a rank one matrix.
A column times a row, that's
a rank one matrix, that column
is the basis for
the column space.
Just one dimension.
OK.
So I know that much
about the matrix.
But now there are two more
facts about the matrix
that I want to notice.
First of all is the
matrix symmetric?
That's a natural
question for matrices.
And the answer is yes.
If I take the transpose of this
-- there's a number down there,
the transpose of a a
transpose is a a transpose.
So P is symmetric.
P transpose equals P. So
this is a key property.
That the projection
matrix is symmetric.
One more property now
and this is the real one.
What happens if I do
the projection twice?
So I'm looking for
something, some information
about P squared.
But just give me in terms
of that picture, in terms
my picture, I take any
vector b, I multiply it
by my projection
matrix, and that
puts me there, so this is Pb.
And now I project again.
What happens now?
What happens when I apply
the projection matrix
a second time?
To this, so I'm applying
it once brings me here
and the second time
brings me I stay put.
Right?
The projection for a point
on this line the projection
is right where it is.
The projection is
the same point.
So that means that
if I project twice,
I get the same answer as I
did in the first projection.
So those are the
two properties that
tell me I'm looking at
a projection matrix.
It's symmetric and
it's square is itself.
Because if I project
a second time,
it's the same result
as the first result.
OK.
So that's -- and then here's the
exact formula when I know what
I'm projecting onto, that line
through a, then I know what P
is.
So do you see that I
have all the pieces here
for projection on a line?
Now, and those --
please remember those.
So there are three
formulas to remember.
The formula for x, the formula
for P, which is just ax,
and then the formula for
capital P, which is the matrix.
Good.
OK.
Now I want to move
to more dimensions.
So we're going to have three
formulas again but you'll have
to --
they'll be a little different
because we won't have a single
line but -- a plane
or three-dimensional
or a n-dimensional subspace.
OK.
So now I'll move to
the next question.
Maybe -- let me say first
why I want this projection,
and then we'll figure
out what it is,
we'll go completely in parallel
there, and then we'll use it.
OK, why do I want
this projection?
Well, so why project?
It's because I'm as I mentioned
last time this new chapter
deals with equations Ax=b
may have no solution.
So that's really my
problem, that I'm
given a bunch of
equations probably too
many equations, more
equations than unknowns,
and I can't solve them.
OK.
So what do I do?
I solve the closest
problem that I can solve.
And what's the closest one?
Well, ax will always be
in the column space of a.
That's my problem.
My problem is ax has to
be in the column space
and b is probably not
in the column space.
So I change b to what?
I choose the closest
vector in the column space,
so I'll solve Ax
equal P instead.
That one I can do.
Where P is this
is the projection
of b onto the column space.
That's why I want to
be able to do this.
Because I have to
find a solution here,
and I'm going to put
a little hat there
to indicate that
it's not the x, it's
not the x that
doesn't exist, it's
the x hat that's best possible.
So I must be able
to figure out what's
the good projection there.
What's the good right-hand side
that is in the column space
that's as close as possible
to b and then I'm --
then I know what to do.
OK.
So now I've got that problem.
So that's why I have
the problem again
but now let me say I'm
in three dimensions,
so I have a plane
maybe for example,
and I have a vector b
that's not in the plane.
And I want to project
b down into the plane.
OK.
So there's my question.
How do I project a
vector and I'm --
what I'm looking for
is a nice formula,
and I'm counting on linear
algebra to just come out right,
a nice formula for the
projection of b into the plane.
The nearest point.
So this again a right angle
is going to be crucial.
OK.
Now so what's -- first of all
I've got to say what is that
plane.
To get a formula I have to
tell you what the plane is.
How I going to tell you a plane?
I'll tell you a
basis for the plane,
I'll tell you two vectors a one
and a two that give you a basis
for the plane, so
that -- let us say --
say there's an a one and
here's an a -- a vector a two.
They don't have to
be perpendicular.
But they better be independent,
because then that tells me the
plane.
The plane is the -- is the
plane of a one and a two.
And actually going back to my --
to this connection, this
plane is a column space,
it's the column
space of what matrix?
What matrix, so how do I
connect the two questions?
I'm thinking how do I
project onto a plane
and I want to get
a matrix in here.
Everything's cleaner if I
write it in terms of a matrix.
So what matrix has these
-- has that column space?
Well of course it's
just the matrix
that has a one in
the first column
and a two in the second column.
Right, just just let's be
sure we've got the question
before we get to the answer.
So I'm looking for
again I'm given
a matrix a with two columns.
And really I'm ready once I
get to two I'm ready for n.
So it could be two columns,
it could be n columns.
I'll write the answer in
terms of the matrix a.
And the point will be those
two columns describe the plane,
they describe the column
space, and I want to project.
OK.
And I'm given a vector b that's
probably not in the column
space.
Of course, if b is in the column
space, my projection is simple,
it's just b.
But most likely I have an
error e, this b minus P
part, which is
probably not zero.
OK.
But the beauty is that I know --
from geometry or I could get it
from calculus or I could get it
from linear algebra that
that this this vector --
this is the part
of b that's that's
perpendicular to the plane.
That e is perpendicular is
If your intuition is saying
that that's the crucial fact.
That's going to
give us the answer.
OK.
So let me, that's the problem.
Now for the answer.
So this is a lecture that's
really like moving along.
Because I'm just plotting that
problem up there and asking you
what combination --
now, yeah, so what is it?
What is this projection P?
P. This is projection P, is
some multiple of these basis
guys, right, some
multiple of the columns.
But I don't like writing out
x one a one plus x two a two,
I would rather right that as ax.
Well, actually I should put
if I'm really doing everything
right, I should put
a little hat on it --
to remember that this x --
that those are the numbers
and I could have a put
a hat way back there
is right, so this
is this is the projection,
P. P is ax bar.
And I'm looking for x bar.
So that's what I
want an equation for.
So now I've got
hold of the problem.
The problem is find the right
combination of the columns
so that the error vector is
perpendicular to the plane.
Now let me turn that
into an equation.
So I'll raise the board
and just turn that --
what we've just done
into an equation.
So let me I'll write
again the main point.
The projection is ax b- x hat.
And our problem is find x hat.
And the key is that b minus
ax hat, that's the error.
This is the e.
Is perpendicular to the plane.
That's got to give me
well what I looking
for, I'm looking for
two equations now
because I've got an
x one and an x two.
And I'll get two equations
because so this thing e
is perpendicular to the plane.
So what does that mean?
I guess it means it's
perpendicular to a one
and also to a two.
Right, those are two vectors
in the plane and the things
that are perpendicular
to the plane
are perpendicular
to a one and a two.
Let me just repeat.
This this guy then is
perpendicular to the plane
so it's perpendicular to
that vector and that vector.
Not -- it's perpendicular
to that of course.
But it's perpendicular to
everything I the plane.
And the plane is really
told me by a one and a two.
So really I have the equations
a one transpose b minus ax
is zero.
And also a two transpose
b minus ax is zero.
Those are my two equations.
But I want those in matrix form.
I want to put those
two equations together
as a matrix equation and
it's just comes out right.
Look at the matrix a transpose.
Put a one a one transpose
is its first row,
a two transpose is its second
row, that multiplies this b-ax,
and gives me the
zero and the zero.
I'm you see the --
this is one way -- to come
up with this equation.
So the equation
I'm coming up with
is a transpose b-ax hat is zero.
OK.
That's my equation.
All right.
Now I want to stop for a
moment before I solve it
and just think about it.
First of all do you see that
that equation back in the very
first problem I solved
on a line, what was --
what was on a line the
matrix a only had one column,
it was just little a.
So in the first
problem I solved,
projecting on a line,
this for capital
a you just change
that to little a
and you have the same equation
that we solved before.
a transpose e equals zero.
OK.
Now a second thing,
second comment.
I would like to since I know
about these four subspaces,
I would like to get
them into this picture.
So let me ask the question,
what subspace is this thing in?
Which of the four subspaces
is that error vector e,
this is this is nothing but e --
this is this guy, coming in
down perpendicular to the plane.
What subspace is e in?
From this equation.
Well the equation is saying
a transpose e is zero.
So I'm learning here that
e is in the null space
of a transpose.
Right?
That's my equation.
And now I just want to see hey
of course that that was right.
Because things that are in
the null space of a transpose,
what do we know about the
null space of a transpose?
So that last lecture
gave us the sort
of the geometry of
these subspaces.
And the orthogonality of them.
And do you remember what it was?
What on the right
side of our big figure
we always have the null
space of a transpose
and the column space of
a, and they're orthogonal.
So e in the null
space of a transpose
is saying e is perpendicular
to the column space of a.
Yes.
I just feel OK, the damn
thing came out right.
The equation for the equation
that I struggled to find for e
really said what I
wanted, that the error
e is perpendicular to the
column space of a, just right.
And from our four
fundamental subspaces
we knew that that
is the same as that.
To say e is in the null
space of a transpose says
e's perpendicular
to the column space.
OK.
So we've got this equation.
Now let's just solve it.
All right.
Let me just rewrite
it as a transpose
a x hat equals a transpose b.
That's our equation.
That gives us x.
And -- allow me to keep
remembering the one-dimensional
case.
The one-dimensional
case, this was little a.
So this was just a number,
little a transpose,
a transpose a was just a vector
row times a column, a number.
And this was a number.
And x was the ratio
of those numbers.
But now we've got matrices,
this one is n by n.
a transpose a is
an n by n matrix.
OK.
So can I move to the next
board for the solution?
OK.
This is the -- the key equation.
Now I'm ready for the formulas
that we have to remember.
What's x hat?
What's the projection,
what's the projection matrix,
those are my three questions.
That we answered in
the 1-D case and now
we're ready for in the
n-dimensional case.
So what is x hat?
Well, what can I
say but a transpose
a inverse, a transpose b.
That's the solution
to -- to our equation.
OK.
What's the projection?
That's more interesting.
The projection is a x hat.
That's how x hat got into the
picture in the first place.
x hat was the was the
combination of columns
in the I had to look for those
numbers and now I found them.
Was the combination
of the columns of a
that gave me the projection.
OK.
So now I know what this guy is.
So it's just I multiply by a.
a a transpose a
inverse a transpose b.
That's looking a little
messy but it's not bad.
That that combination is is
our like magic combination.
This is the thing which is which
use which is like what's it
like, what was it
in one dimension?
What was that we
had this we must
have had this thing way back at
the beginning of the lecture.
What did we -- oh that a was
just a column so it was little
a, little a transpose
over a transpose a, right,
that's what it was in 1-D. You
see what's happened in more
dimensions, I --
I'm not allowed
to to just divide
because because I don't have a
number, I have to put inverse,
because I have an n by n matrix.
But same formula.
And now tell me what's
the projection matrix?
What matrix is multiplying
b to give the projection?
Right there.
Because there it --
I even already underlined
it by accident.
The projection matrix which
I use capital P is this,
it's it's that thing, shall
I write it again, a times
a transpose a inverse
times a transpose.
Now if you'll bear with me I'll
think about what have I done
here.
I've got this formula.
Now the first thing that
occurs to me is something bad.
Look why don't I
just you know here's
a product of two matrices
and I want its inverse,
why don't I just
use the formula I
know for the inverse of
a product and say OK,
that's a inverse times a
transpose inverse, what
will happen if I do that?
What will happen
if I say hey this
is a inverse times a transpose
inverse, then shall I do it?
It's going to go on videotape
if I do it, and I don't --
all right, I'll put it
there, but just like
don't take the videotape
quite so carefully.
OK.
So if I put that thing it
-- it would be a a inverse
a transpose inverse a
transpose and what's that?
That's the identity.
But what's going on?
So why -- you see my question is
somehow I did something wrong.
That that wasn't allowed.
And and and why is that?
Because a is not
a square matrix.
a is not a square matrix.
It doesn't have an inverse.
So I have to leave it that way.
This is not OK.
If if a was a square
invertible matrix, then then
I couldn't complain.
Yeah I think -- let me
think about that case.
But you but my main
case, the whole reason
I'm doing all this, is
that a is this matrix that
has x too many rows, it's
just got a couple of columns,
like a one and a two,
but lots of rows.
Not square.
And if it's not square, this
a transpose a is square but I
can't pull it apart like this --
I'm not allowed to do this pull
apart, except if a was square.
Now if a is square
what's what's going on
if a is a square matrix?
a nice square inv-
invertible matrix.
Think.
What's up with that
what's with that case.
So this is that the formula
ought to work then too.
If a is a nice square invertible
matrix what's its column space,
so it's a nice n by n invertible
everything great matrix,
what's its column
space, the whole of R^n.
So what's the projection
matrix if I'm projecting
onto the whole space?
It's the identity matrix right?
If I'm projecting b
onto the whole space,
not just onto a plane,
but onto all of 3-D,
then b is already
in the column space,
the projection is the
identity, and this is gives me
the correct formula, P is I.
But if I'm projecting
onto a subspace then
I can't split those apart and I
have to stay with that formula.
OK.
And what can I say if -- so I
remember this formula for 1-D
and that's what it looks
like in n dimensions.
And what are the properties that
I expected for any projection
matrix?
And I still expect for this one?
That matrix should be
symmetric and it is.
P transpose is P. Because
if I transpose this,
this guy's symmetric, and
its inverse is symmetric,
and if I transpose this
one when I transpose
it will pop up there, become
a, that a transpose will pop up
here, and I'm back to P again.
And do we dare try
the other property
which is P squared equal P?
It's got to be right.
Because we know geometrically
that the first projection pops
us onto the column space and the
second one leaves us where we
are.
So I expect that if I
multiply by let me do it --
if I multiply by another P,
so there's another a, another
a transpose a inverse
a transpose, can you --
eight (a)-s in a row
is quite obscene but --
do you see that it works?
So I'm squaring that so
what do I do-- how do I
see that multiplication?
Well, yeah, I just want to put
parentheses in good places,
so I see what's happening, yeah,
here's an a transpose a sitting
together -- so when that a
transpose a multiplies its
inverse, all that
stuff goes, right.
And leaves just the a
transpose at the end,
which is just what we want.
So P squared equals P.
So sure enough those two
properties hold.
OK.
OK we really have got
now all the formulas.
x hat, the projection P, and
the projection matrix capital
P. And now my job
is to use them.
OK.
So when would I have
a bunch of equations,
too many equations and yet I
want the best answer and the --
the most important example,
the most common example is if I
have points so here's the
-- here's the application.
v squared.
Fitting by a line.
OK.
So I'll start this application
today and there's more in it
than I can do in
this same lecture.
So that'll give me a chance
to recap the formulas
and there they are,
and recap the ideas.
So let me start
the problem today.
I'm given a bunch
of data points.
And they lie close to a
line but not on a line.
Let me take that.
Say a t equal to
one, two and three,
I have one, and
two and two again.
So my data points are this is
the like the time direction
and this is like well let me
call that b or y or something.
I'm given these three points and
I want to fit them by a line.
By the best straight line.
So the problem is fit the points
one, one is the first point --
the second point is t
equals two, b equal one,
and the third point is t
equal three, b equal to two.
So those are my three points,
t equal sorry,that's two.
Yeah, OK.
So this is the point one, one.
This is the point two, two, and
that's the point three, two.
And of course there isn't a --
a line that goes through them.
So I'm looking
for the best line.
I'm looking for a line that
probably goes somewhere,
do you think it goes
somewhere like that?
I didn't mean to make it go
through that point, it won't.
It'll kind of --
it'll go between so the error
there and the error there
and the error there are as
small as I can get them.
OK, what I'd like to do
is find the matrix a.
Because once I've
found the matrix
a the formulas take over.
So what I'm looking for
this line, b is C+Dt.
So this is in the homework
that I sent out for today.
Find the best line.
So I'm looking
for these numbers.
C and D.
That tell me the
line and I want them
to be as close to going
through those three points
as I can get.
I can't get exactly so
there are three equations
to go through the three points.
It would it will go
exactly through that point
if let's see that first
point has t equal to one,
so that would say C+D equaled 1.
This is the one, one.
The second point t is two.
So C+2D should come
out to equal 2.
But I also want to get the third
equation in and at that third
equation t is three
so C+3D equals only 2.
That's the key.
Is to write down what equations
we would like to solve
but can't.
Reason we if we could solve them
that would mean that we could
put a line through all
three points and of course
if these numbers one, two, two
were different, we could do it.
But with those numbers,
one, two, two, we can't.
So what is our equation Ax equal
Ax equal b that we can't solve?
I just want to say
what's the matrix here,
what's the unknown x, and
what's the right-hand side.
So this is the matrix is one,
one, one, one, two, three.
The unknown is C and D.
And the right-hand
side if one, two, two.
Right, I've just
taken my equations
and I've said what
is Ax and what is b.
Then there's no solution, this
is the typical case where I
have three equations --
two unknowns, no solution,
but I'm still looking
for the best solution.
And the best
solution is taken is
is to solve not this
equation Ax equal
b which has which has no
solution but the equation that
does have a solution,
which was this one.
So that's the equation to solve.
That's the central
equation of the subject.
I can't solve Ax=b but magically
when I multiply both sides
by a transpose I get an equation
that I can solve and its
solution gives me x, the
best x, the best projection,
and I discover what's the
matrix that's behind it.
OK.
So next time I'll complete an
example, numerical example.
today was all letters,
numbers next time.
Thanks.